are we live
hello
[Music]
beau
rick
oh god i just remembered where we were
oh no
hello
welcome
how's everybody doing today
i just ate some food
some sausage rice and egg
time
beautiful
i don't understand the appeal
of asmr but
yeah
did you get the tv i did i did get the
tv yesterday
i did
it's poggers can i go increase my health
please
like having this much health is just all
right i'll try
we almost beat reichardt
with no health
right card will fall what up haskell
no hp for me okay
understood
we'll just die
rick has returned
bam
i got a block there
who needs health that's a good example
of why we need health
i actually have to block
or i die
we'll keep going though because we did
almost beat him yesterday with
12 health
12.
yeah yeah you guys are all saying bubble
tear
yeah yeah yeah okay i don't have any
runes got it
nope that's bad
what up silly
nerd
the soldier of god rick
is here
man
oh we will be leveling up the sword
absolutely
get them can you name your mimic
well we'll just call him morty yes
that's a great idea
i want to watch this just for today
one time
i've heard soldier of godric as the boss
with the most health would make sense to
upgrade vigor
i don't know where you heard that from
because he dies in two hits
very well
very well
i don't think soldier of godric uses a
shield does he it's just a big sword
i think
now
how many times did you complete the game
i think like six or seven times
that's not good
i can't even see
what oh he pulls it back
he pulls it back out man i forgot
he got so close there
randomly bro
oh this would be so easy if i just had
more health
welcome back yoda
yes we will make rick the elden lord
that is our
goal will become eldenborn
bang nice very good so far
very good
i don't have oh god
i did not have stamina
i like that you interact with your chat
yeah i don't know why streamers don't
interact with their chat a lot i i don't
get that
after you beat the game soldier of
godric lorvan
you know i could make a soldier of
godric vid that's just like full of just
not true information but it's all a
giant meme that could be fun
like a fan fiction
all right here we go
yanks it back out
didn't hit me that time though that's
good
stagger
yep
one hit
big hit
decent
gotta stay close gotta keep
hitting might be able to plow through
this man i don't know
this is scary
one more
run
easy dude
easy for god
easy for rick
look at that vigor what did i get hit by
did i stand in the lava for a second
very good very good
good stuff boys
i think it's made out of rock like his
face is just plastered onto the side
just plastered
all right good job good [ __ ]
i thought that would take a lot longer
than it did
can i level up my vigor please
or do i does it have to be here for the
for the run
and just keep leveling this
and probably this
no
oh god
come on man
we're gonna die so many times
listen
um
i want to say beat the game like this
but you decide oh bro
this that would be a meme run
this isn't supposed to be a meme run but
it's it's quickly turned into one
all right
fine
if it gets too hard and we can't like
literally can't finish then
we'll we'll we'll switch it up but for
now
we've got
this
is this the sword he uses
i got out voted
i really did
is this not a mean run it's not supposed
to be
it's it's not
but here we are
having a good time right
this patch is still over here
now you've gone and killed reichardt
you scheming little bastard
cripes you make this nonsense seem well
this is rick's percent speed run perhaps
soldier godric has 384 hp
how much do i
a have mess
but how else could it end
when daddy is head over heels courting
lady blasphemy
[Laughter]
well
here i am
untethered once again
goodbye my friend
what a weirdo okay
i have
wait
i have 455.
you're telling me my i can't go lower
i literally can't go lower
fair enough
it's a part of the run now
you
it's true then it's true
you've defeated our lord the soldier of
god rick
has defeated pray to
our lord was yet weak
you have taught us that
defeat is not the end
our lord is immortal look at this man
will one day rise again
stronger
until then
i must stay the path
and do my part yes you should
now i'm taller than you
anyway i will leave the volcano manor
before long
i suggest you do the same how can i drop
my health more
the champion who walks the tainted path
shines all the more
i always was an admirer
yeah i am pretty cool
eater ass
that's sus
i don't want to eat anything she's got
going on
ah my thanks
let's see
oh
my thanks chat my thanks
seppuku rick does not need sepuku
so
you killed reichardt damn straight
and some other talisman drops max hp
how about you know we just go we just go
with 12. like we're good
but any road the volcano manner is no
more
though we may yet fulfill an old promise
we hunted our own kind
and took what was theirs
and with everything in hand
the time has come to rise against the
earth tree yeah
i wonder what rick would do like what
ending do you think rick would pick
would he pick the flame a frenzy ending
i think he would
let me go end this guy upstairs
i don't know if we've done that yet
sepiku
have you guys not learned yet that i
don't pronounce anything correctly and
it's on purpose so that i can make you
guys comment on my videos saying well
actually if it's pronounced like this
and all that does is push the video out
to more people
almost died
i died
so i i literally can't get hit
or i die
he would pick the most chad ending
he is a chad
you like that uppercut though
mm-hmm
yeah he kind of [ __ ] on me huh
it'll cost you points at a job interview
i've got a job i have a job i don't need
an interview
i'm good
what
you guys are really gonna make me keep
doing this huh
guy annihilates me bro
take more damage
but
oh
i thought i had a baldicon's blessing
rick
has the greatest determination
of all in the lands between he will
always come back to slay his enemy
this isn't fair this isn't fair
nice
yeah mess up that chair buddy
boom
shoot
owned
owned
he's on the table nice
oh yeah you can break the table
i don't even want his wheel
these will die in one hit might as well
use talismans that give you benefits at
the cost of higher damage like radagon
seal
yeah actually that's true
that's actually true
but
more damage taken but there it is
yeah you can power stance but power
stancing doesn't really matter
uh when you die in one hit
no it more damage taken you have more
health but it's more damage taken
so it kind of doesn't matter
but other attributes are increased as
well
can we upgrade at all
no we need smithing stone threes where
can we get those
should i just sell rikers um remembrance
i don't think we we definitely don't
need it at all yeah we can always get it
back too
um
he's just gonna have insane strength and
dexterity
hmm
i already went there i you only get uh
smithing ones and twos from that crystal
cave
get the hug i bet well actually she's
gone we already did that part
we need to go
i mean at this point we're just gonna do
cleanup for all the bosses but let's
just progress the story i suppose
we need to go
oh [ __ ] we're already like deep bro
oh my god we have to face morgot
with one hit
that's not gonna happen
no cap
oof
oh no
it's close to there bell has three air
force level three and four stones
okay i really do want that i already
went here
it's not in that one
is the seal tunnel the the one under
here
i think so
use the shackle
does the shackle really even help that
much when you die in one hit
oh it's an altus
what's this one down here then
i'm gonna check it out
because there's a boss in there that we
need to beat anyway
oh i know you guys are talking about now
the one that goes to reichard's uh
divine tower yeah yeah yeah i got you
i got you
well never mind we're not going in there
okay
we will go
this way then
yeah it's two crystallines
if you kill morgot like this
plus c will just be thrown your way
yeah
it is pretty attractive isn't it
let's go up here first
that's academy crystal cave
do you guys just have like amazing
memories
this whole stream's gonna be me dying to
moor god isn't it
yes rick does receive many maidens
can i use that big sword
or do i have to use this one
the like the biggest sword
because i think this is the one that
soldier of god
rick
actually uses
no
all right
we'll keep it going
saying a guts build
i already got like 42 strength
and 12 vigor
in a game where vigor is probably one of
the most important stats you can have we
don't have any of it
good stuff guys
good stuff
i am a soldier of god
rick
my name is rick
hey yo what up
86 damage
yeah what uh ash of war can we use
can i use butt slam
that'd be kind of fun
you guys want ass slam
yeah just don't get hit right guys
that's all we need to do
just don't get hit
it's really that simple isn't it
oh god
nice
this has turned into a soldier of godric
run yes
i'm out
i'm scared
just click their head
true
oh god
very nice
reduce the boss's hp
to zero
while seemingly keeping yours above zero
exactly
very true
i don't know what grace mimics are for
can i just turn into a mimic or no it
sends out one
right
look at this
wow
i can't rest
oh we will be modding this game for
future streams
absolutely
i want to do this challenge around
though
100
so we know where everything is
oh god
is this doable
yep
rick
well
this ain't good
that armor is tacky no you're tacky
and your mom is too
get owned
sick
just jaw just dodge
all right you guys do it
you guys dodge
you're tacky and i hate you
yup guys don't forget to like the stream
i don't think i've ever said that before
but just do it
do it now
thanks
oh this is ridiculously hard with 12
vigor
good start
yeah
okay hold
that's bad that's not good we don't like
this
good thing i healed that
couldn't power stance it
that man has some reach
got your toe
stop swinging
we gotta heal one time
that's that's luck right there
let's go baby
the power of rick
cannot be stopped
rick
will spore jon
no matter the adversary
rick is giga chad you know what's funny
he actually is
look how we have three of the helmets
the bell's not from the boss i know we
already got it we already got the bell i
just wanted to do it
because we had to
good job guys good job
i mean we killed the real rick so the
imposter rick excuse me so fast we don't
really know
what rick can actually use
but i think rick
doesn't have time to learn incantations
all rick knows
our jump attacks
yeah this is reichard's tower
right coat
you get health back for killing people
which we really don't want but here we
are getting it
i don't know why i rested okay
i think the lore question we all need to
ask
is rick
god
is rick himself an outer god
[Music]
yes and he should have all of the great
runes
boom
boom okay
should we wear this no we shouldn't
we shouldn't
rick lives and dies by the way of the
sword get these arrows out of here
peasantry
let's see
reduces damage and impact of headshots
are headshots even that important in
this game
greatly raises maximum stamina raises
equipment load but we don't we're not
gonna have anything else on so it
doesn't even matter
we don't need spells
critical hits restore hp that could be
good
uh
let's just do dexterity for now okay
where do we go now
do we need to go to morgot
oh god
new video on the outer gods including
rick
i think it would be funny to make a
video about rick
and it would just be like a meme video
i feel like people would get mad at me
though they'd be like none of this is
true
you have no evidence to support this
theory
none
i need to be careful i really need to be
careful huh
didn't i already go up here
i swear i did
i don't even need to do this
that's yoshi
there we go
did you change your sword to quality
should i do that
can i do that
let's see what ashes of war we have
since he's all about that quality
yes sir
do we do butt slam
yes or no
i think yes
oh heavy
oh
it would all be strength then
okay i see no and yes
lots of yeses but slam is lame it'll
kill you more often
i feel like he would have storm stop
right
and it would be quality
heavy thrust that's repeating thrust
but it oh keen
it would all it would just be decks
hmm
i don't think he would do blood
you have strength index quality is the
way to go
i think so too
i think we do this
let's try it and always change it
that's kind of lit
[Music]
it switched to quality didn't it
no rick doesn't need bloodhound stuff
he's better than that
owned
[Music]
okay i thought he could do
never mind
i thought he might be able to thrust
forward
boom
godric versus melania
you mean rick versus melania or actually
godric
because we know
actually in the lore
how that goes
what's the next game you want to play i
don't know yet we'll have to wait and
see i just really like this one
[Applause]
uh
oh my god
just annihilated
oh we we quite literally can't mess up
bloodborne's next
could be
should have gone with butt slam he just
butt slammed me you're right
that ain't a blood slam
oh my god
uh
[Music]
that was close
[Music]
um i'm scared
i'm panicking
gotta go over calm down all right here
we go
not a time to swing understood
that's a healer
what's
go
i actually did that
i'm good at this game
holy [ __ ]
this is a new game plus this is a
straight run
oh my god
i'm nuts
damn
that was so clean
i got hit a couple times though a few
times but didn't kill me
you should play bloodborne or dark souls
completionist run
play whatever you think would be fun
honestly i'm scared to play other games
man i ain't gonna cap
like i want to ride the train of elden
ring for as long as it'll take me but
you know i mean
it's still scary level up endurance a
little bit
let's go
good stuff boys
i don't think i have any of these
honestly
don't need the blues
i should have one though
i should have one
just in case
now
the real challenge
you get the turtle talisman i did
well now i can wear it
i didn't get the turtle talisman let's
go get the turtle talisman
that's
here
wait until you get the new game plus
seven
no thank you
i think this already
already hard enough
let's go turtle rick
those are funny oh excuse me dog
talisman you're right you're right sorry
sorry
yeah let's get the stream to 69 like 69
likes guys just uh because it's funny
i love dogs
rick
loves dogs
rick would never hurt dogs
i'm just rp walking everywhere okay
there we go very nice very nice
is there a soldier of godric
summon
damn our stamina is going off
getting 500 subs overnight
did we that's good
that is good we'll take it
rick is a good guy he really is
[Music]
all
right let's get it
what's at the top of storm hill
mr killington
uh
claw talisman why would we need that
he went to 74 likes
okay don't unlike please don't do that
let's get it to 420 let's go for that
420 likes
that's the next funny number
whoop
oh the oh that's what you mean yeah i'm
stupid even though i just asked that i
forget
my memory is really bad
let's go over here
it boosts jump attacks
that's a huge part of my build
is doing that a lot
why 420 yeah he doesn't know
what do you guys think this is right
here
what is this
it looks like a crib for a baby
well there's someone in it though
who is this
mickela
golden order principal
want to read it ta
would it be info no
it's a sex puppet
nice
nice guys
[Music]
it's a magic book get give to the turtle
pope oh [ __ ]
rick
does not take fall damage
all right let's go to turtle
jarburg
where's turtle again
where's muriel
isn't it over here
am i tripping balls
i swear it's over here or have we not
seen muriel yet
prove me wrong you can't that's because
we we actually can't you're right
daddy dog pope
northwest of lakes tower
yeah i know it's the church of vows
you know what there's a really good way
to do this hold on a really really easy
way
to get there
without having to work
need to go to the
um
this would be easier
i thought we went to the turtle pope
i guess not
where did he flee
[ __ ] your books
my day has been excellent ass how about
yours
it's been an
excellent
day that's where i'm going gilgamesh
that's the plan stan
rick doesn't wait
for elevators
rick is impatient
rick regrets his impatience
rick doesn't die
rick was testing elevator
elevator works
test complete
rick is the physical manifestation of
the greater will
rick's beyond the greater will he's not
just a man manifestation
the greater will is a manifestation of
rick
literally my favorite character in the
game
you're tarnished aren't you probably i
welcome you to the church of vows
i am mirial
steward of this sacred chamber
my apologies for the unseemly state of
affairs
do you know the origin of this rick is
the greatest will
church of vows
well that is a shame
but who can blame you
the shattering they should change the
game's name from elden ring
to rick
of something very dear
it is elden ring 2.
soldier of god
by the matrimonial bond between red oh
his eyeballs
of the full moon elden rick
the monuments of both houses
the earth tree of the capital
and the academy of real lucaria
oh was there something you needed
you are free to show yourself around
i would serve as your guide rick is the
writer of the game
he told george rr martin what to write
you are free to take it with you
unless perhaps you are in search of
instruction
in which case i will share all that i
know
give prayer book
golden order prince principia oh what
have we here
very well let us both learn together he
doesn't even know he is not native to
the world
it is but a contrivance
all things can be conjoined
oh
all things can be conjoined together
interesting
rick does not need incantations
goodbye
i'm gonna get this though
we could do that s
it's a possibility
rick doesn't need absolution
rick doesn't make mistakes
i knew it was over here okay
i'm honestly just
scared of morgot i really am i'm scared
i'm scared
i'm scared
killed a bell-bearing hunter at night
yeah we tried to do that it did not go
well
he really did embrace heresy like
actually did
you guys think more got scared of rick
i would be
rick is terrifying
rick
has no fear
rick kill
howie
can you uh stop for a second
nope
why was it that thing was going off bro
oh my god
just wouldn't stop
it just kept attacking
thing would had it out for me man it saw
rick and win all out
my god
little do they know that rick doesn't
die
am i allowed to summon melana for the
fight
i think we shouldn't use the stomp
the stomp doesn't seem very good
never gonna give
maybe it's better than i thought
what
i'll take it
rick will roll you
never gonna get
give you up
that is a black knife assassin
melano would be cool for story reasons
that yeah i think we can summon melano
imagine getting rick rolled by rick
you know what we could do if this gets
too hard is actually summon you guys
that would be fun
so then we we can keep it going
let's give it a shot though
whatever ending chat wants when we get
to the ending
what is thy business with these thrones
ah
godric the golden
the twin prodigies
michela and melania
general radon at least you have a psy i
still can't get one god
i would love to play demon souls luna
princess ronnie
willful traitors oh
you don't like his feet
right here when he grabs it did it at
one point light on fire like a little
little ember to it
pillagers
emboldened by the flame of ambition it
doesn't do that anymore
i swear it like ambered up a little bit
why does mine not do that i have
everything at max settings
why would they change that last of all
kings
i'm scared
i ain't gonna cap
this is gonna suck
as i said
let's go melano
want these foolish ambitions to rest
i don't want to use the shackle i don't
think it'll be worth
this this is gonna be [ __ ] hard bro
i'm gonna have to master these moves
i got ripped
he he he knows that i haven't slept much
that's why he's uh
he just wants us to go to sleep
i would say moog is stronger than morgot
for sure
dude i can't even see bro and we got
bots
another freaking bot
why my stream dude go somewhere else
nobody's gonna fall for your tinder [ __ ]
[Music]
bro okay
they're coming
oh sorry it's saying tinder is
overpriced
be gone foul bot
why do you have no health
because i'm rick
i don't need health i forgot to summon
melania
not bad
what up
but these foolish animations to rest
he did some weird-ass cartwheel and it
threw me off
that was good for a second
why does the game consider malaques
black blade and the godslayer greatsword
legendary armaments
does it not
okay everyone report these accounts too
that would probably help
they're just so weird
this is going to be so hard boys
i beat this guy for the first time
yesterday no summons congratulations
there is a flask you can use to stop
moog's like
knee heel thing
but these foolish animations to rest
dang bro
i would say this is the boss i struggle
with the most in the game as well
his move sets very hard for me to learn
yeah i should probably abandon the runes
no no we just got to get good
i thought i was to the side enough
wow that came in [ __ ]
god i hate these attacks man
this is gonna be really hard guys like
really really hard
he needs a golden sticker
he needs some type of
recognition
um
i probably should change the ash of war
i don't think the shackle does enough to
warrant it
oh your reach is insane bro i just
wanted to go heal
can't level up bigger chat told me not
to
he's periable i'm not very good at
perry's though
yeah if you were level 250 fighting
morgot you were very overleveled
very very very overleveled oh my
goodness
did we do butt stomp
so did i lose the
original
or can i just remove it
undo enchantment
oh i see
okay
um
i don't know if i would like quick step
yeah where's the soldier of godric ashes
that would fit
where do you say that was again
12 figures too much
top of storm hill
graveyard outside of stormville
over here
isn't there a graveyard over here
everybody googling
this is fun though it's just really
[ __ ] hard it this is not meant to be
a challenge run
at all but here here we
are adding it
i was thinking of this graveyard right
here
to the south
that's good to hear yoda
little forest south of stormville so
it's right here
okay
dun
there are a lot of knights in here that
would make sense
do we know where
why are you all attacking me
ow
i am your leader
i don't see anything in here
what should i use whatever rick would
use
willful traitors all
yo cletus mcfetus
why is your and are so small is that a
pointed face
is that what he uses does he use this as
xalwinder it's all wendyr
and we're just using some weak [ __ ]
and thank you for the 20 man that's
super kind of you thank you
i think you have to use torrent to get
to a little hidden area oh
but thank you cletus
are we using the wrong weapon
i do not see anything over here
thank you very much cletus you're the
man you're the freaking man dude
there is no
there ain't nothing here
i have the right sword
hmm
should i ruin farm for 50 hours
uh if you think that's fun go for it
yeah i don't see anything here
you don't have to go up the main road of
the castle oh it's a little bit lower
then
we killed soldier of godric didn't we
rune farm and watch anime
beautiful what a beautiful life
i am very happy for you
okay no
look for jellyfish near that
okay
searching
for jellyfish
it's up there
it thank you
oh it's a little cheeky area
leave me be
well there's a lot of jellyfish
yeah does rick use a gun
here it is
godric soldier ashes
hey that makes sense
let's go check out roderica thank you
for the help chat
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh yeah ishin uses a gun greetings are
you here
yes i am oh my god
there we go
lit
oh i have enough i just need rooney boys
eachine is rick's cousin
i can believe that
i could definitely believe that
all right we need a glove four but we're
gonna make it work for now okay
okay
let's give it another shot guys
i'll pick a rick
pvp bill cosby build sleep arrows for
days
that's gross
but slightly funny
what kind of funny we also had oleg at
one point but
it doesn't really fit our build does it
okay here we go
no we're doing a
soldier of godric build
go forth men
fight proudly
25 damage
i should have used melano as well
i forgot
it's cartwheel [ __ ] man oh my god
go forth men
i was not going well
uh to get runes get the same rooms fast
without the animation you can sell them
numbers i i know i've done that many a
time i just didn't want to in that
moment
okay we're gonna sell in mel summon
melano we're gonna summon our boys we're
gonna we're gonna be patient
wait for the right moments
we're gonna be fine
right guys
right okay
i didn't know if he followed that up at
all
okay
did not think that would hit me
unfortunately
[Music]
storm stops not very good okay i wanted
to test it best
that's better we're learning we're
learning
wow yoda you're kind of nuts at the game
aren't you
get the flask that gives you a shield
yeah for one hit
isn't this it yeah
and then i guess physical negation or
that's poise
that's that's what i have on okay let's
do that that's fine
and then ash of war
i don't even know what to use now
i just want to use the nor like the one
i had before but i wouldn't be able to
use it it's not going to work on him
i'm [ __ ] doing it man we're gonna
give it a try
oh the bubble tears the one you guys are
talking about
we're gonna be fine i'm not worried
about it at all
might take a minute though
right
gotta get out of here get out of there
don't touch me
what
ow
get him guys
what slam
that was going so well it that one shots
you
man i think i was just too close
how did the butt slam do i didn't see
not bad
[Music]
we got this
gonna happen
the hold
he just
he holds on to attacks for so long it's
so frustrating dude
and then sometimes i feel like he whips
those things out really fast
yeah i'm not gonna use any more arcs i
mean it's not like we use arcs that
often and there's plenty of them
is turbler just way
behind
are there other soldiers of godric
what is that
and not summon melano
[Music]
break it up back it up
[ __ ] you and your
your weird ass attacks man
the delays on one second i just don't
think you're live turbler
hit the live button dog
first time i fought this guy after a
couple of death deaths i used come amen
command yeah yeah
this ain't an intelligence build
this is actually one of the dumbest
builds ever but it's fun
i don't know if perry's going to be very
good against him
only slash sucks
but it might be good for this
get him guys
nice
my game froze okay
good
i need a distraction
that's unfortunate
oh my god mel and i got owned
i like it melano i like it
can't tell when to go
okay
phase dose
dude the little thing in the ground
popped in the air and i couldn't see him
anymore
oh it was going pretty good
does anyone else notice that dee's armor
looks like he can join twin i mean he
does have a twin so that would make
sense
that was a good attempt
progress
it's doable
[Music]
i didn't summon the boys oh no
okay
that's not bad damage
get him
that almost wasn't worth it
that's a whiff
good i can freaking ban this bot
i'm scared
oh come on
man shall not be forgiven
oh my god melano
she went in
i panicked
it's gonna be real hard now man
so hard to see
i want to hit there but i'm nervous of
getting one shot
he stopped his attack
halfway through an attack to do another
one
[Music]
gross
really good attempt though
what he's he's like changing attacks mid
attack though
like out of nowhere he's like i'm gonna
do my swirly spins
and then i die
sucks man
i was dodging everything left and right
though for a minute there holy [ __ ]
okay
youtube fix your bot problem holy crap
all right
let's go again
you need to increase your hp no way do i
actually
wow
never would have thought
oh come on dude
i never said they came on only one of
the streams
well
yeah they only bought it like one time
now it's like every stream if that's
what you mean yeah
we continue the meme run
i think we should be able to increase
our health but just do
do the rick run because we're trying a
hundred percent the game
this might be too hard with no health
i keep forgetting to do things
i want that explained to me right now
explain
i need that explained to me immediately
that man wasn't even looking at me
just take it off and use the other one
what about my original enchantment is it
just gone now
that kind of sucks
hmm
it's not like we can use it anyway
well we gotta stay on theme albany
i don't think godric
or excuse me rick would use a jellyfish
just level up vigor
you've said that like 40 times
and i don't understand
whoa
all right hi
thank you stan
get up guys
what did you see that what just happened
he was stuck
melano
that hurt
probably not a time to use that
the thrones
it's fine shall not be forgiven
come on you [ __ ]
i shouldn't have said nothing
[ __ ]
shut up stan
i shouldn't have said it
we have such good runs but it all ends
with one mistake
one mistake boys
that's all it takes
one kiss is all it takes
i hate it here
yeah we're at plus seven right now
545.
[Music]
is he stuck okay
that's big
that's big big
oh i rolled bro
i should have stood in the tree
the thrones
stand by my curse
such as
thy partners
shall not be forgiven
come on
i feel good about this one
he got stuck and stopped look at that
what
um
i don't even know what happened
he wasn't even looking at me again dude
it's so doable though
it's there
we just need a god run a god rick run
that's what we need i have to focus so
hard though i can't even talk
oh grease
what's what's he weak to
maybe he doesn't like fire
it's morbid time
i wasn't panic rolling you were
dude everything's weak to bleed
i got impatient there though i just
wanted to see the initial damage
which was kind of dumb
well
is he weak to magic
anti-dragon effects
he's resistant to holy
i don't have any blood though
sweep the poison huh
we'll try the fire the little fires
i think every enemy in the game is weak
to blood loss even moogs weak to blood
which is so weird
that was close
the fire's already gone
gang up on him guys
that [ __ ] delayed attack gets me
every time
is that what the dragon is is that rot
we were close to what we were doing
with what we were doing
that doesn't last very long
let's try magic
[Music]
stan
that meme is dead
and nobody here knows what you're
talking about
goofy
that's so unfortunate that he was aiming
at me
what hit me bro what was that
he's looking the other direction
it's happened like three four times
bro
tail
man
[Music]
uh
melna goes in i go inside
not be forgiven
i've
freaking rolled and nothing happened oh
no we can definitely upgrade the sword
more which is probably what we need to
do because this is just really really
[ __ ] hard
if i mess up at all or like one roll
doesn't go through i'm dead
is this this is nuts
it's like the hardest thing i've tried
to do in this game i think
this is too slow
for these foolish ambitions to rest
i want to do it like this for some
reason because i'm stupid
summoning melania makes more god's hp
higher
well
let's try it without
put these foolish ambitions to rest
nope wanted to run not roll
too late i thought i could get both
[Music]
he's like getting wrecked by my guys and
he's just going after me dude
oh my hope is slowly draining out of my
body i can feel it seeping out of my
butthole
is the zeil hander on theme
he did have less health
what's up booted how are you
get your health bar bigger you clearly
don't know what we're doing
he doesn't even know where he's going
bro that staggered the [ __ ] out of me
all right
you know what guys
i'm making an executive decision
i'm making an executive decision
i'm doing it i'm doing the thing
i'm still
thinking of my decision
but it will be an executive one
this is not a challenge run
yay or nay
because it's not
this is supposed to be 100 play-through
that is quickly turned
into a challenge run for no for [ __ ]
no reason
so
i say we we continue the theme
we continue the theme
of god
rick
and we can come back to a challenge run
another time
i'm gonna put it to a poll
because i care about y'all and you're
what you would like
challenge run or no
it's that this we're making our 100 run
much more challenging by doing this
i will put it to a vote but i will i
will still decide
not what you signed up for it's not
and never mind i'm not gonna do a poll
i think god should have a lot of vigor
go for vigor
yeah i
i think a challenge run in the future is
a great idea like maybe a rune level one
challenge like we've tried before we
could do that but this is this isn't a
challenge run it has turned into that
but we are going to struggle for
days on this
which we shouldn't
but i also don't want to feel like a
[ __ ]
you hate democracy this isn't a
democracy
come
is it okay win
son of a [ __ ]
where can i get a larval tear
we've already done this twice
i would birth thee
as a sweeting
fair and fine i feel like we could do it
too i really do
get out of here you bought
ew
village
i think we killed the rune bear we did
kill the rune bearer
are they really in here
where's the larval tear in this area
yeah we killed the guy who turned into a
bear
right behind the house on the right
it's near the grace
mean house on the left
you're the best thank you
we will do a challenge run chat we will
but this isn't that this isn't that
we know how fun it could be though we
can we can do crazy challenge runs if we
really want to
but for now
i say we kick it
we try and do everything we possibly can
do it possibly can do in the game
oh i know i could kill margaret like
this
or morgot
but bruh
it'll take us days
now
is it i wish to yet again
yet again
now
perfect just kidding okay
we got five
good
it would take an insane amount of
grinding but we'll do that in the future
is this good
i think so
um
[Music]
i think so
ah
health
i forgot what it was like
all right let's see how fast we can do
this no roll challenge
you're a demon
a demon
yeah we'll upgrade strength from now on
we will keep we will keep
the soldier of god rick
we'll keep doing that
it's fun role play
man this health bar my god
forgot what it was like
wow i didn't die
what is this madness
what the
that was insane
[Music]
no idea what i just did
damn melanoma damn melody
shall not be forgiven
oh god
[Music]
this is a lot easier with more health
okay
oh melania
did he just extend that attack like
by a lot
now
no
no
no
[Music]
[ __ ] you
i am
very stuck
so
ah
foreign
[Music]
oh
the
tree wards off
you are a bad person
just as high
godric doesn't lose rick
the soldier of god
needs no thrones
thorny boys
fought
kill
destroy
good [ __ ] stan
uh oh
that one made it through
it's another one
kill
good job stan
oh my god they're going crazy right now
it's because we beat them
you know what they think you guys are
horny because i beat that boss
that's exactly why they're doing that
allow me a moment
to converse with you
you are unable to enter the earth tree
no
preventing i hate the bots on youtube
too it's so annoying the thorns are
impenetrable
a husk of the ur trees being
that spurns all that exists without
the only way to stand before the elden
ring
and become the elden lord
is to pass the thorns
my purpose
serves to aid in that very act
so i'd like you to undertake
a new journey
with me
to the flame of ruin
far above the clouds
upon the snowy mountaintops of the
giants how many of you guys in your
first playthrough thought that when you
beat morgot you beat the game
and guide you like you did it down the
path or you were gonna go to the final
boss after that lord
let's go
shall i turn your runes to strength yes
let my hand rest upon you my mods are
great
my mods are great when they're here
we won't talk about that though your
ambitions
the principles you would follow
sometimes my mods don't be here
but i am mod
you knew there would be more i didn't
i didn't at all
we should probably finish everything
right in this area so
how do i start um
like where where can i go to start dung
eaters thing
because i you need to get one of those
uh
those thingies i could probably just go
in the sewer right
probably could
and find one in there
grave near the waters
yeah we already talked to him in the
round table but he doesn't want to talk
to you until you have a certain item
but well actually
yeah let's let's go try it
do i have a seed bed curse
we about to find out
also
that was the item i was thinking of i
asked you not to disturb me
be thankful of the whole serenity
it is all that keeps your death and
defilement at bay
yeah see we need a seed bed curse
where can i get one of those
is there one here
i didn't think he meant purchase
the beginning of lay and elders one
oh fake round table we could do that
yeah let's do fake round table because i
want to look at it as well
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
we are going for whatever ending chat
wants me to do when we get to it
for now we don't know but we're gonna
have all the options at the end if you
guys want me to do flame a frenzy then i
won't
you know get rid of it obviously
silly doggies
we need a pickle rick ending
reject that one a bit
nerd
the age of rick ending exactly
[Music]
nice we got a wet blade we got a hammer
that's actually kind of cool
buy my sword
got a hero's room that's big poggers
oh wait you guys don't say poggers here
on youtube do you
got a rooney boy we'll take it we like
rooney boys
smithing five
huge
oh i guess you guys do say poggers huh
calling finger i love fingers
poggers kappa
i really
really doubt they're gonna mess up the
dlc i think the dlc is gonna be great
this has got to be it
there we go baby
what's poggers
you
you are poggers
was watching the stream in the stream
recognized places around table hold a
lot of people thought it was just a case
of asset reuse no it's a part of the
lord it it's cool
let's go
let's go
chat what's your favorite ending in the
game
no
wait
you have felt the curse
i can smell it on you
the box
get tender
apparently my seedbed is ripe and
waiting
it was a brief respite i must say this
game is great how it is dlc would
tarnish it no bro everyone wants more
content
ronnie
dustbourn
ronnie
then the pokemon gold mask playing with
frenzy seems pretty split between
everything
gundyr
have you played any of this game yet
stan
yeah you did you played the [ __ ] out of
it trapped in the sewer jail below the
capitol
i think i have no idea kill you
and you follow your corpse
then the pox will truly be your own
going
okay let's go to the sewers
to start this bad boy up
um i think from here we can find it
i mean don't you guys want to find
mikala
know more about mykola more know about
um
[ __ ]
godwin
right
like come on boys
nice air milled that one
let me move
sewers do you think we'll fight
dragon lord and radon at their full
power i hope they do some time travel
thing i want to see radon when he's not
crazy
you know
i really really do i think that'd be
awesome
like what if we got to talk to radon
like what if we didn't even have to
fight him
we just talked to him
i would love that
nerd ass rats
the final boss is underrated i think
ratagon's great
i don't like the elden beast though
i think the elden beast could have been
a little bit better if they let us ride
torrent then the elden beast would have
been cool
i feel like i should upgrade my [ __ ]
[Music]
find girl even in the [ __ ]
that's gotta be like
non-english
bots
what them
bro i don't want to fight ronnie because
i think she'd low-key decimate us
i think ronnie's the strongest character
in the game
and we don't even know
let me out of here
everything that matters to you
for generations to come
i am the dumb gator
a scourge upon the living
gross
who are you
leave
your jail
i've been here long enough
i will kill again
and defile each corpse with care
just to be sure
that when they're reborn
they'll be cursed
along with their children
and their children's children
for all time to come
this voice acting is really good
oh we'll kill again
and defile each corpse with care
just to be sure
that when they're reborn
[Music]
the [ __ ]
whoa
[Music]
that doesn't help
this man shaved
who said he's low-key hot
this is gonna be a problem
run it out baby we're out of here
yeah he is weak to fire but i could just
run away like this
like a little weenie
what up lord
i am lord
lord lord lord
[Music]
weenie hut juniors
uh what the heck
have a great day dominic
[Music]
boom
yeah dude i'd love to use rainbow arrows
rainbow arrows are lit
nice
we need to upgrade bro should we use the
xyle hander or however you say that
i don't even i don't even think i've
ever found that weapon before
yeah i like led zeppelin i listen to a
lot of tulle and foo fighters as well
where where are those
because this is pretty bad
blind sort well we can't do that so way
later
so it's kind of not possible
at the moment
oh yeah he hits a lot bro
didn't need those
no i haven't killed patches because he's
a part of a quest line and stuff
and dun dun dun
well i guess i should ask is the
xyle hander good
i don't even know i've never used it in
in this game i used it in uh dark souls
one
you said weeping peninsula it's on the
weeping peninsula by the merchant
um
the merchant right here
not as good as in previous games well
i'll use it just because i haven't used
it before that sounds funny
that's the bastard sword
i'll buy one of those
far west side
like this way
merchant on the beach
way over here oh west side's this way
i'm stupid
that was east
i'm dumb
i don't know which way to go
i don't know what i am
okay
gotta gotta
damn this game's [ __ ] pretty you can
you believe there's people out there
that say this game doesn't look good
what a nerd
what a bunch of nerds dude
they're probably playing on a
ps4 or something
even then i bet it looks pretty good
i've been here
son of beach
hey yo what up well
there's been an age how can i help
[Music]
this isn't a legendary weapon is it
we might need those
have a safe journey
my german is awful
i don't know how to speak german
hey oh my god oh my god dude
holy
oh yeah
was that better
dude this thing's too long
oh my god
well
where have you been hiding i took you've
now mattered
okay we need two more ones
then we'll need
a few more
yeah okay
it's all big boy sword
purchase
yeah i'm compensating for something with
this sword bro
i'll defy you next come to the outer
moat
we gotta go fight the boy
actually a real sword
yeah this thing is freaking huge bro
huh oh i needed two more ones oh my god
i'm so
gotta run all the whoever designed to
put
where you can buy [ __ ]
across the round table
from where you can actually use those
items as a silly goose
isn't the great sword bigger i don't
know this thing's pretty long
this one's thin though but if you're
into
thick
never mind
three more
okay i don't have enough rooney boys
though
well yeah i do
i can sell them
how many more than i need three
and then we need to go find where we can
get
smithing stone threes
flame birds is still better i don't know
what that is but we're gonna try this
one it looks fun
my chat's german now
where are you all from
you don't mind me asking
i'm from the middle of the united states
so i don't you know
super basic
okay where where can i get smithing
stone threes
australia
hong kong
croatia washington dc
bulgaria
northern germany canada
middle of nowhere asia
cool
india austria a lot of you guys are not
from the us that's surprising
netherlands we got you stan
kurdistan region of iraq
oh cool mexico
norway
british columbia
i had a guy on my golf team from british
columbia sweden
portugal
i really want to move to portugal
someday but that might not be until i'm
like in my mid-30s be a long time
before i would decide to move out of the
us that's such a big
big thing to do
murica
alaska
no
never seen
never met anyone at least in real life
from the netherlands
i'm 27
just turned 27. i've never been to
brazil i've heard it's dangerous though
i've heard brazil's quite dangerous but
then again i live in america so i don't
know what i'm talking about danger for
you walk to a grocery store and die so
or go to school
sag where can i get smithing stone
threes
you guys told me and i already forgot
you said it was some uh
not here
like i thought
but somewhere else oh eric wait didn't i
get that i didn't offer the bell bearing
we
literally did that yeah yeah yeah we did
that
houston
utah
what up alex
i freaking forgot to give them the bell
bearing i'm so silly
wow
i'm such a silly goober
okay i have six we need
two
six
is it always 12 that you need
to get through the threes
i might have bought too much there but
we're fine
i'm so silly
brazil is a very highly represented and
society so it's being dangerous isn't
that all surprising
i don't know
nope that was exactly the amount we
needed
now we need fours do i have fours
how much damage are we looking at here
222 okay okay
that's pretty good
oh we got the fours baby
i mean i have
six so i need to buy six more
i bet bet
[ __ ] you morgot
eat one two three four five six okay
it's big bunk time
some areas
of some states scotch gotcha
back already no matter
okay
oh i didn't need that many so
smithing stone fives were there smithing
stone vibes
you see how inefficient i am at this
because i just focus on one thing
without thinking of the rest and then i
forget to do the rest and now i have to
run back and it's probably really
annoying to watch
i don't think we were dead
no okay cool cool cool
kill kill kill kill kill kill kill kill
all right
let's move on chaps
i guess we could check
oh we gotta go uh fight the boy we gotta
go out here
oh no
blackguard's gonna be uh not looking too
good down here is he
uh oh
yeah we killed morgot
we had to increase our health though
uh oh
it's a bot
[Music]
yes
or no we did not fight radon as rick
i'm curious about the us though is it
research that dangerous
research that dangerous
well i don't know if you've been
following like recent news but it's
i mean yeah
it's pretty [ __ ] awful
oh i went the wrong way whoops
i can just go this way
damn
i think the us is very dangerous
welcome ramy
what is he doing here like he's fine i
thought we were supposed to meet here
everything's harder to fight on touring
that's decent damage bro
damn
and then i get smacked by a bug
bro america's tits
you must be hungry
dude i wasn't even too handy oh my
goodness
all right mate
want some more crap dear
about the dung eater yeah
then i was seen here again
never thought i would
what he does to those bodies
it was
it was him
no question
that monster
yeah that's a super political thing lone
wolf but
i mean
i don't care if someone disagrees with
me i don't think we should have guns
here
i think at the very
the very least what should happen is we
should not uh sell
[ __ ] assault rifles
which is just insane to me
but i don't want to get too crazy with
that that's so
political we're playing elden ring here
that's a very large topic that i don't
even want to start
that's my opinion though
who needs an ar-15
you must be hungry
what's the lore behind america's tits
have you seen america
she got some ass bro
she really does
don't we meet here
yeah
i think we have to come back
i'm gonna wait till day
yeah 18 years old you can buy an ar-15
but you can't
you can't drink
oh thank you
stains quick with it
red mirror
melania get hers from probably your mama
why is this the only guy that talks
about it i don't know
he's the only guy that like talks that
way as well it could be like the region
he's from
dang
no the drinking age here is 21 but you
can buy
an assault rifle in ammo at 18.
i just think that's silly
that makes
actually no sense at all
are lots of great things about america
but there's very clearly
things that are wrong with it
but the problem is we don't do anything
about the things that are wrong
i think that's
a giant issue
we just don't do anything about what's
wrong we just [ __ ] we talk about it
and then ignore it
just silly
oh god
oh boy
serves me right
fitting bloody end
for a jumped up little [ __ ] with big
ideas
whoa
that's gross help me help
what do you mean
i don't want to get cursed
just let me die the dung eater got him i
don't want to live like this
not anymore
so
please
got the curse
our boy's dead
rip black guard there he is
crab
crab
crab
so
got some reach on this thing
finish them off crab come on
did he just
whoa
did you see
that i didn't know he died like that
what the hell
do you see that
he got like ripped up from the ground
[ __ ] bug
dude he like
it's like uh that god wins
thing
it it definitely wasn't the crab oh it
was
it was the crabs death blight oh
okay thank you
that was wicked
that was kind of cool
all right chat can we can we get apps in
the chat for our boy blackguard here
apps in the chat
i think sir
f
he was a good man
but he did deserve it
all right good [ __ ] guys
so if we go back to the round table
just out of curiosity here
can you do a round table characters lore
and their connection to the story of
each other
it's actually a really good idea
you could do that
that's a great idea yes see he's still
here
there you are
you warded off my blessing
despite the curse stirring within you
no one has succeeded in that before how
i thought
then it hit me
that you are in fact
me
and i
i'm the doggy that's one way to tell
yourself that my man
that must receive the blessing
give me your blessing
defile my flesh with the said bed curse
again and again until it is done
until a cursed ring coalesces
that might one day defile order itself
countless i have killed
and countless so i have defiled
and soon the fruits will be born
hundreds will be reborn cursed
and they'll bear thousands of cursed
children
who bear tens of thousands more he
really is evil incarnate be born just
like me
and they'll kill
and defile
and bless in my stead
their rotten fools
my fate was the grandest
most brilliant of them all
my corporeal flesh lies in the sewer
jail beneath the capital
give it your blessing
defile my flesh with the seedbed curse
until a curse ring coalesces that may
one day defile order itself
all right
let's get it
we gotta go back
why does he sound so sus he's the dung
eater bro he is
as sus as sus gets
he is what we call here
sassy baca
should make that an emo
all right never been hit by this flower
before but here we are getting hit by
the flower
do we not like sassy maka
bang
what happened to the hand
there he is
[Music]
hello
along with their
their
children
children
we'll see his face again for all time to
come
use the seed bed curse or leave
i think we have to don't we
let's do it
yeah he's an omen wannabe
that does not sound fun
[Applause]
uh
curse you golden order
one day
well now what
do i kill him
or do i go to the round table
do i kill him
make him a puppet then kill him go to
the round table
okay oh that's how he ties into
oren huh
what's up muhammad
you need at least five seed bed curses
okay gotcha
okay
how many do i have
probably a key item
got two death roots
not a key item
i don't think i have any right now
because i used them didn't i
i think so
if you make him a puppet you fail as an
ending
corwin dies
when you burn the er tree
there's two at the halek tree
feeling good today mohammed how about
yourself i turned him into a puppet with
one pretty sure they are a key item
yeah i think i i had to use them
okay we'll find more as we go along
orwin should be
recording
last
he was on this bridge which he's
probably up here now
yeah
he's really here let's go find him
i'm muhammad too well hi mohammed
another muhammad
you need selfish potion to turn him into
a
puppet do we want to turn him into a
puppet or do we want to not
yeah i don't think we want to make him
into a puppet
yeah i've been the game of bunch up just
very i don't remember how to do this
quest line specifically
i know how to do corn though
i'm pretty sure they're up there with
the gold mask
these guys are creepy scary
how do you guys think they're gonna use
these coliseums
i think they're gonna be pvp arenas
whenever they flush out the pvp
yep there he is
whatever is the matter
please i implore you continue
continue your reflections your rhythms
i must be the one to record them
what matters this issue of radicand
really
the earth tree heart of the golden order
lies before our very eyes
why must these qualms come to you now
we were on the very cusp
oh was that you
sorry i hardly noticed i'm a little
shaken since the master ceased his
movements
the master's reflections at
the ever brilliant gold mask
while still a precise calculus
pve boss raids
until he simply ceased
now the master is facing quite the
puzzle the golden order is founded on
the principle that marika is the one
true god
however
the name of marika's second husband king
consort radigan
also appeared
who exactly was radican
the master is stumped
his finger has remained still ever since
rudigen's name was discovered
curse my mediocre mind
the master only has me
and here i fail him
imagine liking finger movement as much
as this guy huh imagine
so now we have to go find uh that
ratagan is america
which is
if i can go this way
i'm not gonna have enough faith to even
do this
because you have to use that incantation
to do the thing
yeah i'm gonna have to learn the law of
regression
which didn't we get from that
and then we gave it to muriel
so i got a rebirth twice
or you need in right right that's what i
meant
i need 37
yeah i guess i could just get a larval
tear and do that right
i suppose so
i gotta go the other way
uh how long we've been streaming for
almost three hours
that's not bad
uh the fact that nobody knows who
radagon even was is proof that they're
they were always the same being
i think so too
if nobody knew who he was yeah
or corn is an idiot
he's an idiot
see we gotta do it in front of this
right here
regression alone reveals secrets
okay
in talisman that boosts it
you can get into gear up
and then use physics to hit 37.
do i have any stuff like that
i hope your interview went well man i
hope you get the job
good luck to you
um
[Music]
doesn't this increase in no this
increases faith this doesn't do [ __ ]
yes i am cosplaying as soldier of god
rick
the burger king mask no we don't have
that i'll just i'll just do the lar we
just need two larval tears we actually
don't have to do this one right now
so
you know what i think we're gonna do
i think we're gonna call it for today
and come back tomorrow we've actually
done a lot today
we have done a lot today
i think we're gonna call it
and we will come back tomorrow
this is a fun stream though i'm really
enjoying this
either we'll come back tomorrow or the
next day on sunday i usually stream
like in the mornings or like early morn
not like
mid mornings into like early afternoons
usually cst est whatever
um but yeah i do have some stuff that i
need to do and i think the stuff that we
want to do will take too long
and then we won't actually get anything
done so
we can just come back tomorrow that's my
plan so
really appreciate all the support guys
you guys are freaking awesome
i've been having so much fun streaming
on here it's actually such a treat
so enjoyable to do so because you guys
are so great
um
either tomorrow or sunday because i
think i do want to work on a video
tonight and tomorrow
try and get that out to you guys
tomorrow at some point
um
but yeah
we'll see i'm going to start i want to
do a snapshot
lore video and see how that goes i'm a
little nervous about that but we'll see
how it goes
um but i'll see you guys next stream
again really appreciate it all love to
you guys
have a great rest of your day i'm not
going to tell you what the video is
about you goof you got to find out
anyway
love you guys have a great rest of your
day and i will see you
either tomorrow or sunday so have a
great day enjoy your weekend
see you soon
bye bye